la jeune fille va devoir démontrer son
avocat qu'il y avait un des éléments qui
caractérisent lequel le 24 avril 2010
est une jeune fille qu'on va appeler un
sahara rentrer chez elles après l'école
et au collège il est en classe de 6e
elle a 11 ans est sur le chemin elle
fait une pause au parc est là elle est
abordée par un homme de 28 ans est pas
la première fois qu'il lui parle il y a
déjà causé deux fois dix jours avant et
quatre jours avant à chaque fois en
interpellant les uns héros madmoizelle
com vous êtes jolie est ce que vous avez
un copain est ce que c'est ce jour là et
on recommence le dia vous attendez qu'il
y votre copain quand ça se fait je
n'avais pas de copain vous est si jolie
et ils parlaient pas elle répond pas
vraiment et puis il à propos il propose
de la suivre et elle le suit elle le
suit dans un immeuble du quartier ils
habitent dans le même quartier
même s'ils ne se connaissent pas et a
finalement ils montent dans l'ascenseur
dans l'ascenseur il embrasse les arrive
au neuvième étage et là ils ont une
relation sexuelle sur dans la cage
d'escalier puis à l'intérieur de
l'appartement où il demande de la suivre
une fellation et ensuite ils se séparent
il lui dit ce que je peux contrôler mon
téléphone est ce que tu veux je te
raconte paris elle lui dit non elle s'en
va elle est paniquée elle estime avoir
été agressée elle appelle sa mère qui
est à ce moment-là à paris en
déplacement qui paniquait l'oci appelle
les policiers qui viennent prendre son
témoignage et qui vont l'entendre
une enquête est ouverte une plainte pour
viol est déposée qui va en fait aboutir
à une audience qui devait se tenir à
cette semaine mais qui a été envoyé au
mois de février mais la surprise et
c'est ce qui fait en fait l'intérêt de
ce dossier et l'effroi pour certains
c'est que le parquet ne poursuit pas
pour viol lui-même pour agression
sexuelle comme cela arrive parfois quand
ses rangs qualifié mais seulement pour
atteintes sexuelles c'est à dire qu'ils
considèrent le code pénal considère
qu'on peut avoir une réaction
avec une mineure mais là la famille de
la victime on va dire en tout cas de la
jeune fille considère que la relation
n'était pas consentie et que donc il y
aurait dû avoir des poursuites pour viol
une loi de 2010 prévoit il peut y avoir
une contrainte morale si un écart d'âge
important entre la personne qui a été
violée et le violeur en l'occurrence
c'est le cas elle a 11 ans il a 28 ans
elle assure qu'il connaissait son âge
car lors de la rencontre
elle lui a montré son cahier de liaison
qui ont payé deux collégiennes dans
lequel il est bien marquée qu'elle a 11
ans ils contestent ce fait il dit il
pensait qu'elle avait entre 14 et 16 ans
mais le parquet a choisi de considérer
qu'en l'occurrence les éléments qui
peuvent caractériser un violent
mettaient paris et donc il n'est pas
poursuivie pour de tels faits
du coup il ya une jurisprudence qui
existent même et pas très clair c'est
l'appréciation du juge
au cas par cas la cour de cassation a
pris une décision qui fait référence en
la matière mais concerne seulement les
enfants très pas d'âge pour les enfants
de moins de 5 ans hier qu'il ne peut pas
y avoir dit fermement et de consentement
mais entre 5 et 15 ans il n'y a rien de
fixé